Maisomomomomomomomomomomomomomox
changements climatiques.
icici ce qu'a constaté, sur
place, Elisa Serret.
- Quiconque est agriltlteur le
sait : la besogne requiert
temps, passion et patience.
Et dans le cas dcececececececec.
Car pour accéder à sa terre,
il doit traverr r la route 132
plusieurs fois par jour.
ANDRÉ RIOU, agriculteur
- Il faudedededededededededededs
et ça ne traverse pas
instantanément la batteuse;
ça va lentement et on ne peut
pas aller plus vite.ezezezezeze?
- Oui je vais essayer de vous
montrer ça.
- Il dit devoir patienter,
des fois, jusqu'à p p p p p p p.
C'est qu'au grand dam d'André
Riou, la 132, ici, fait office
d'autoroute.
♪ ♪ ♪l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'0
s'arrête avant Trois-Pistoles
pour ne reprendre qu'à
Rimouski. L'anomalie fait
en sorte que la rout v v v v v e
en Gaspésie.
50 km de discorde qui ont
souvent fait l'objet de
tractations politiTETETETETETEÉi
- La route 20, vous savez, elle
s'est arrêtée à Rivière-du-Loup.
MARC-YVAN CÔTÉ, ministre des
Transportsononononononononononoa
finalisation de l'autoroute 20.
YVON VALLIÈRE, ministre délégué
aux Transports
- Le prolongement dee e e e e e,
ça va être la seule solution
valable.
NATHALIE NORMANDEAU, ministre
Ressources naturelr r r r r r re
Cacouna jusqu'au BIC.
JEAN D'AMOUR, député de
Rivière-du-Loup
- Juste avant la vststststststsx
pont à construire.
- L'histoire du prolongement de
l'autoroute 20 est une saga
truffée de dét0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0,
le gouvernement de le CAQ l'a
réinscrit dans le plan québécois
des infrastructures, mais
une vive oppntntntntntntntntntn.
SÉBASTIEN RIOUX, membre "Le pont
de la 20, ça ne tient pas debout
- Il y a 40 ans peut-être que
construireququququququququququq-
être, mais pas en 2022.
- Sébastien Rioux est membre
d'un groupe citoyen opposé au
qui inclut la construction d'un
pont au-dessus de la rivière
Trois-Pistoles.
est en jeu. C'est la protection
de l'environnement ... Le GIEC
ne cesse de le rappeler
l'urgence climatique. Construire
une route, c'est destitititititx
déplacements.
- n n groupe propose un bouquet
de solutions pour contrer les
problèmes de sécurité et de
transport collectif inter-
régional, bonification du
transport ferroviaire et une
réfection de la route 132,
incluant l
contournement.
- Bien sûr que réfléchir un peu
et innover ça demande un peu
plus d'efforts. Nous, c'est ceqn
petit peu plus.
- Si la majorité de la
population et des élus est
favorable aux travaux, en raisot
du nombre élevé d'accidents sur
ce tronçon de route, presque un
tous les trois jours en moyenne
années, un élu s'y oppose
toutefois : le nouveau mrere de
Trois-Pistoles.
PHILIPPE GUILBERT,
- On parle de 27 hectares de
teeses humides... de zones
humides, 6.7 hectares
d'érablières qui seraient
216 hectares de terres
cultivées, là on parle de terres
en culture.
- L'élu de 30 ans croit auqu'ilr
la rivière Trois-Pistoles.
- C'est une source d'inquiétude,
en fait, que ce pont-là affecte
grandement la qualité de
la rivière.
- Ce qui l'inquiète surtout,
c'est le manque de transparence
du ministère des Transports.
- Il y a une citoyenne,
justement au début de l'été,
qui a demandé les études
géotechniques. Il est arrivé,
le document est à 90 % caviardé
et le MTQ par la suite nous
dit : "Bien là, on est content
des informations qu'on a et
on a juste pas besoin de les
diffuser.
- Philippe Guilbert dit qu'il ne
peut pas non plus ignorer
les im
sa ville. Car selon lui,
plusieurs municipalités ont
souffert d'être contournées
par l'autoroute comme à
Certains commerces ont même dû
mettre la clé sous la porte.
- On veut des réponses. Là,
le MTQ nous dit que le projet de
c'est la meilleure solution,
mais on a pas d'autres solutions
qui ont été proposées.
- Pour André Riou, la solution
est évidente. S'auauauauauauauae
l'environnement, il croit que
la sécurité et la qualité de vie
des résidents exigent qu'on
passe enfin à l'action.
autant d'argent a fait des
améliorations dans l 5 50,
60 dernières années, on aurait
déjà eu une autoroute, puis
parlerait pas de
l'environnement.
- Même s'il reste encore bien
des étapes à franchir pour que
le projet se concrétise,cocococ,
sur le plan politique, toutes
les conditions semblent enfin
réunies. Une inconnue de taille
demeure : celle de
l'acceptabitité sociale,
difficile à ignorer en 2022.
Radio-Canada, Trois-Pistoles.